over than that and across the sea such a
venture and brush to see if young man
lower trap they and conquer bake Canada
so we've reached toronto now and we are
in our second hostile called hi toronto
or wait overs over here and now I'm over
here and in this one we we have a shared
one but it's okay cuz they're pretty
cool isn't that right and the pain live
music dancers
so this morning I woke up super early
I'm still waking up in England time and
I'm not hard core enough to enjoy a
hostel my first nite owl's bit freaked
out as strangers around me so I was
really mean and I made Laura wake up a
bit area than she's used to they have
seven but it's okay because we're gonna
go to Toronto Island today and party
it's pretty peaceful and then up the CN
Tower that see it's better when you
should order
Wow
we're walking around the island and we
found the girl for those of you they
didn't know laura is absolutely go
obsessed hence the name green goats
travel on her travel blog so look how
happy she is Laura show them how happy
you are that he found goats do your
reaction when you first saw the goats so
if yours on the islands and now we're
gonna go on the CN Tower all the way up
there
our time in Toronto has come to an end
but it was so much fun with live music
and everything at the hostel and
everything that we did there was awesome
but now we're on our way to the capital
which is Ottawa just so you know my
second night in the house to went pretty
well i managed to sleep and it was fine
being around the strangers it's quite
fun actually get to meet a lot of pretty
interesting characters so I'm excited to
see what the next website
Laura and I were driving down the
highway and she stops to show me
something that she says it's very
important apparently it is Canada's
equivalent to the Statue of Liberty and
it just reminds me of well oh I'm going
to show you what it is it's a giant
Apple I'm just really confused I don't
know why it's here no it does no one no
one knows